and what's been the most fun part of
being called the falling skies world so
far for you guys not having to hide from
my landlord nice thing for now I know do
you think um this is the first I've ever
been on this just big on a show yeah
like being a part of something this big
so just the whole ride of what's been
five almost six years now from start to
finish
yeah we've finished but um we shot the
pilot in we have been holy crags we shot
the pilot and then a whole you and I
before we went into production and then
it was a significant significant amount
of time before did aired as well so
we've been working for about two years
before it even came on yeah I didn't
think max had been born yet still in the
conceiving stage in the pilot midnight
yeah so to be part exactly what drew
said to be part of something that you
know it's rare enough for a pilot to get
picked up let alone for a show to go
past its first season the second season
third season so to be on something
that's relatively long rung and running
with consistent casts and relatively
consistent crew it's like I was like
college or something going off in the
same place every year and it's so rare
when I tell I've told the story before
but I borrowed this season one I
borrowed it because I figured there'd
never be a season two and I thought well
as well take a little something for
myself you know since I'm never coming
back so this is Pope's original necklace
from Steven that season one and it's
been on my neck for four or five years
but just said what reason hasn't broken
and I just keep using it so I don't have
to put it on when I go to work because I
just go home with it and I go come back
with it because that's what I've been
doing but you don't you don't have any
idea if these things are gonna last so I
ended up borrowing this watch thank you
other cast members think about our show
is that all our clothing and props look
in a normal context completely
disgusting so if we were to that's kind
of in it's like homeless chic homeless
yeah yeah
derelict shell Gabrielle yes another
question
oh that you were giving me glory which
it's true I'm just kidding no I think I
think a big part of it is we're blessed
with a really tight cast that we all
really dig and respect each other and
it's been like that since the beginning
and it's only grown in great ways and I
don't I think that that's a testament to
how much passion you know we have for
and other people have for it we've also
had an interesting situation where our
writers have changed almost completely
three times out yeah we should have been
a huge deficit for us you know things
could have gone and gotten really
scrambled up but by changing basically
every season really I guess the first
and second was just kind of built upon
the last kind of thing yeah they've all
worked off of each other and therefore
capita very unpredictable we were each
other's support through that though you
know yeah we were the constants also
this it's the fun thing but also gonna
be a little bit scary to it at first it
was very fun because it's not your
typical episodic show so every week the
you know the PAS and the grips and the
sound guys reading the scripts cuz not
to see where what they're gonna do with
like what's gonna happen next and then
where the scary part comes in all of a
sudden you realize oh god did I die
oh no I come back think out or whatever
you know so you start freaking out a
little bit and you start the rumor mill
starts going around you start having fun
poking fun all the characters like
Connor you die this week what I die when
you're gonna die but but it's nice to be
a part of a show where it is
unpredictable and it's neat to see
what's coming next as opposed to it's
just another crime
with a different face saying the same
dialogue every week where there really
is an arc it's going somewhere and we
don't know where it's going it's nice it
seems like a fun set to be on what kind
of prank do you guys play on each other
what kind of fun stuff
oh yeah we're out there in the freezing
cold it's 30 below zero we're on our
18th hour it's nothing but fun trying to
think of like actually pranks I mean
we're shooting so fast along that think
I'm sure we've done something a lot of
like Frank's or there's a lot of like
skits that we've moon and I have staged
this just haven't didn't realized like I
remember we had that we had that Med bus
and she'd always be at the front of it
she's like reenact Forrest Gump should
be like this masse like where you sit
appreciate yeah exactly they don't give
us the time of day usually we shoot a
lot of nights on our show and by Friday
night about 6:00 a.m. things tend to get
pretty giddy to say it like there's some
it gets trippy when it gets late if
anything it's it's we got to make sure
we don't kill anybody because they're if
there's knives and weapons and guns and
explosives and so if anything it's not
you know things are loose but never you
never let anything get to it's not on a
phonics guy's show cuz so you've got
horses and there's motorcycles and
there's people getting cranked twelve
hundred pounds of pressure and they're
gonna go 30 feet in the air so it's not
like you know my flick is years before
it takes off there was a story but was
it Peter
like first season with the boat it was
second season second well we were shy
was good where are they like we're in a
boat and like he said that he could
paddle it but he couldn't there's a
scene in the second season where a few
of us I think it's Drew and Sarah and
Peter and I go on mission I think it's
near the beginning the second season we
go on the air talking Peterson coach
please die and we go on this this little
mission and we're supposed to special
spec ops kind of paddle in on a Zodiac
and drew
has just had sailing lessons there's
something the previous year so so he
thinks he knows he knows what's going on
I did and and he and Peter are both
paddling and Sarah and I are just
sitting there and they can't paddle at
the same time like no matter what they
do they can't get the same speed going
so we're out there in this river with 80
people in the beach looking going around
in circles
yeah we're solid 45-mile professional
actors out there making it making it
work what do you enjoy most about
playing your character on the show and
if you could swap with anyone else's
character the kirigi swap with a wine
that's a cool question Doug Jones who
plays Cochise but but only for a day
exercise a guy once he gets in his
wardrobe does not get out of it all day
there's bathroom breaks so he actually
has to pay attention to how much he eats
em and you trade that you trade for does
interest on just for a day markers that
might be I think you'd be wild I would
not trade John Pope for all the
Hartley's in China wouldn't do it yeah
yeah yeah for the Skinner fingers and
like the ability to nonsense yeah my
favorite part of Lord is those is you
know one suggestion is I like her faith
yes it's a it's made me a lot more
open-minded about people who are
faithful about me whatever they are
faithful about whether it be Catholicism
or a different religion or whatever it
just uh looking into it has made me much
more open-minded and I'm very grateful
for it that's cool I like that he's dark
secular worldly but has the as far as
the regular cassock oh he has some weird
stuff happening with him from the very
beginning which has always been
an interesting angle to play and always
comes up in various interesting
incarnations and so that that's always
curious it you know for some reason I
always end up involved in the in the
crazy plots so keeps you on your toes
you